snoopy naturellement emmanuel de la
taille partout dans le monde la presse
écrite le mot et la télévision
l'image s'invectiver semaine la ville
pourtant il est un secteur où le mot et
l'image font depuis belle lurette bon
ménage la bande des six
pour la première fois un congrès
international a rassemblé à new york
les princes de ce monde florissant qui
restent avec leurs personnages leur
bulle et leur donne au matap et bloup
bloup flat ouf sur l'univers des enfants
et de bien les aides
les français ont ainsi fait découvrir
aux professionnels america nos héros
favoris dans ce domaine sans frontières
qui mène du rêve à la caricature
politique
un échange fructueux parmi eux un homme
célèbre qui se montre rarement hergé le
créateur de tat paradoxe tata avait
précédé en amérique son auteur qui vient
de la découvrit la mairie quand j'ai
envoyé
alors
j'ai fait ce que j'avais lu du génie
georges duhamel notamment celle de la
vie future
d'autres choses encore et j'ai fait ça
avec mes idées préconçues nathan qui
suit ce serait très divers elle a changé
votre idée préconçue en tunisie
oui parce que je me montrais que le côté
que j'aurais pu le dire est un virus il
est vraiment positive à merveille
ça vous a plu
fascinant fascinant new york soit matt
en elle même c'est une
c'est quelque chose de précis c'est le
meilleur et le pire c'est le plus beau
et le plus dégueulasse il y aura
peut-être un jour un tintin une nouvelle
amérique caisse puisse être possible ses
costumes possible
et atteint ponctuent vive nieuviarts
quant à lise est elle s'affole en haut
d'un gratte ciel où l'on tire ses nattes
et aussi les 100 millions de bandes
dessinées que consomme la hms york new
york informations première